dating them with the way that you are I
mean when you understand the code it's
you know Plug and Play it's like okay
deal with the girl size her up figure
out what kind of trick she is and then
bam you know you already know kind of
how to how to move so like what's the
code depends on the group I wonder about
how I would be sized up
and please chat don't say nobody's
trying to size you up anyway all right
I'm not everyone's cup of tea but if I
was I just want to know what I'd be
sized up
uh because I just can't imagine any
girls like gonna want to be like hug me
at the beginning of the day
okay you got to be able to adapt based
on the woman that you're sitting across
the table from yeah I have the female
codes in my sleeves I know pretty much
what they all are okay so how are you
adopting to me right now you want me to
be honest yeah close okay I want the
code now and then I'll ask the code
again by the end of it yeah I would say
uh recreational use only no offense so
what's like the old how many codes is
there well it depends on the record wow
no
you know you if you deal with a girl
that's younger that's in her prime years
well you got to understand that she's
more you know inclined to look for fun
if you're dealing with a girl that is in
her mid-20s a lot of times she might be
pursuing you know it depends on the girl
but she might be pursuing some type of
stability or some security and you got
to play at that angle or if you deal
with a girl that's a little bit older
late 20s 30s or not nine out of ten
times she's going to want some type of
security if she hasn't gotten there
already code it's not even that deep
like if you like them or not you don't
need to put them in categories so what
kind of woman do you want sorry
um let's be honest ladies we have
categories too let's just let's just be
real Let's do let's just be real you
know damn well when we meet a guy we put
him in a box
I personally my boxes are yes no maybe
yes no maybe it's like immediate yes
immediate now maybe gotta get to know
this one a little more
Yes No Maybe
and then the chat will be like
never mind sorry
you guys
sometimes you'll be coming for me for
everything it's like damn
I can't say anything anyway sorry I mean
I could deal with whatever my thing is I
need her to come into my life and be an
asset and not a liability
most girls are liabilities to be honest
do you think I think the right woman
though could like really just compliment
you and make you like Progressive also I
will read super chats if I see them
sorry I have the thing
if you have things you want to say you
can Super Chat it or not yeah whatever
but I'm just saying
I'm working for a living here you know I
want to get blessing a monopod but they
really
he really spent a lot on my credit card
last month me and blessing got beef
right now
we got beef because it was a lot so
we're kind of on a budget but you know
anyways well you got to train them no
you haven't in order to train someone
you need them to listen I'm telling you
no woman is listening to you like most
girls come into your life like and if
you don't know what you're doing she's
going to come in as a liability 100 no
you don't train them though you have to
try it's like training a dog you
wouldn't do that oh here we go no but
it's true though it's not training it's
not something like once again it's just
seeing this person actually I actually
do think you sort of trained women I I
I think good women are trainable sorry
sorry well okay but showing the person
respect it's not training so I look at
it like if I'm gonna have a girlfriend
and she's going to be my girl and she's
going to have my title well she's got to
be trained to rise up to a certain level
because I'm going to make her into an
asset buy me a bag do this blah blah
blah take me on trips whatever when they
haven't earned it so you got to try
detrain those bad behaviors out of that
girl and make her an asset into your
life versus a liability most guys don't
understand their value they bring it on
to their life they give her everything
she hasn't earned it she doesn't respect
them she's walking all over him he's
right this is just facts this is just
look at this is just facts he's speaking
fat that's true that's absolutely true
women
you can't give girls everything we then
we don't respect it and it's kind of
like
somewhat similar for guys like guys kind
of want to chase a little bit too you
know take the relationship I know the
guys will be like no no no guys don't at
all and I'm just thinking like
okay I'm sorry guys
would not be
books that sell so well that women have
wrote with like women dating advice if
men don't like the chase a little bit I
understand simps maybe it's just the
simps okay
but some of y'all do okay I'm just being
honest I'm just being honest most people
don't like things that are given to them
for free they don't respect it you're
not getting socks tonight blah blah blah
he's so rude obviously this is your
experience so I can't argue that but I
mean this is this is this is biology
women are hardwired to extract resources
for men it's been that way since the
beginning of time biology rules
everything guys they could sit there and
say oh but I'm doing this and my truth
blah blah blah biology rules you there's
one truth there's no such thing as my
truth female typical blah blah blah
trash
no but I kind of feel like from my
experience if I've gone into if I'm
going into someone's life I would want
to add value so I wouldn't really take
things and I kind of feel when you what
did you just say two seconds ago you
don't add value yeah that's you majority
of women come in meet the guy okay what
can I get from this guy okay this guy's
a Sim I'll just take him out on dinner
dates he could pay I'm never gonna smash
him another guy this guy's hot you know
I can smash him I can hang out with him
this guy he has some utility he's a
plumber okay I could do my Plumbing but
I'll give him a BJ once girls put guys
in roles it's your job as the man to
make sure that you're the top guy and
you got the main role where you're not
investing too much and she's investing
more in you girls own respect men that
they invest in the girl always has to
like the guy more than she likes him no
I think he works better the other way
around when the guy likes to grow more
yeah that doesn't make sense why does it
make sense because women want a man is
better than them so how do I look if I'm
better than you and I'm sitting here
Chasing After You doesn't make sense
women only respect men that they chase
it doesn't work the other way around
once again with this like news I
I hate that that's true but come on like
how many times have we heard on Tick
Tock oh I only like the guys that don't
like me yeah we like being assumed we do
we like to work for it I can't I don't
make the game I just tell you what it is
for women we don't want to wait um we
don't categorize friend zone Orbiter
Chad husband foodie date
for a man so if he's going to treat you
like an option see here's the thing we
can say that women are changing whatever
but we're all slaves to our biology
women are 100 okay with sharing men it's
been that way since the beginning of
time it's I would say it's even more
apparent now with Instagram dating apps
Etc a minority of men are getting a
majority of the women and women are okay
with that I mean walk into a nightclub
walk into a nightclub it's probably one
of the most carnal representations of
human nature all the women are sitting
in one section with a bunch of the the
guys that have the highest perceived
status in that social setting versus all
the other guys are out there in general
admission struggling women always
gravitate towards the best guys and
they're willing to share those guys so
what's your time my type fit feminine
friendly yeah submissive and coachable
and Coach oh come on Myron you're not
going to add him with the fat ass
boobs at like come on
come on you got I'm just like just be
real here you guys are like I have no
type
I usually have a little bit of a type a
little bit like there's something
to be trained
you've got to train women man I know
that sounds terrible he's still talking
she's like I thought this was a date
women don't like it when they get
criticized if I go on a podcast and I
say you know what guys you need to stop
being bums you need to get your money on
point not being fat poses Etc they
actually admire and respect that people
are in the FL in the chat flame emojis
whatever I go on rants on the guys all
the time I'm swaying going crazy it's
like I'm hey bro I know you like to chit
chat and I do too I really need
like-minded female friends but don't
know how to find them can you help me
out oh girl I don't know
you think I know
ah
I wish
um
yeah I got no advice sorry some
questions I have good answers too
because some of my friends really don't
agree with me or even know what this red
pill stuff is I don't
DM me in a preach I think she's trying
to grow me but what she doesn't know is
I'm a black belt in this I've dealt with
10 girls like her at the same time on my
podcast so she's gonna take an L women
rarely get held accountable for their
poor decisions men do though men have to
live in reality women are afforded the
privilege of being delusional so when a
guy criticizes a woman oh my God right
if you don't believe me think about it
if a dude's fat we just call him fat
you're a loser huh form is fat love your
curves girl you go she's rude and
obnoxious oh you know what they just
can't handle you you're strong and
independent fierce we have all these
terms to cover up
female inadequacies but we don't have
these same terms for men I think it just
a lot of it comes from like narcissistic
behavior from men and myself women are
far more narcissistic than that no true
yeah okay and you can answer this
question so easy who's the more
narcissistic gender who is more addicted
to social media social media damn nears
narcissism as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible